for you when did you kind of like want
to expand because you know Instagram's
one business model yeah being a blog is
a business model but you've kind of
expanded the brand into so many
different like branches of like
uh just expanding the portfolio you know
obviously now we have the Jason Lee show
which which uh congrats on the first
episode of cardi B
um but when did you kind of realize like
yo there's just wait there's just so
much more here than just being a blog or
being the gossip site uh when my
Instagram went down because that was
like where most of our Revenue was
coming from and when that [__] was that
2019 it was 20
[__] I don't even it was probably
2017-28 and maybe maybe until it's a
blur now it's been it was too it was I
remember when that happened because I
I would try to there was like a
different page you guys had right that
we had we had a [__] what do you call
those a backup page yeah the backup page
going yeah and then that became
complicated because then Instagram was
like if you lost Hollywood unlocked you
can't have a backup to that because you
lost because you lost it for a reason
company you know whatever it was crazy I
think once I lost that it scared me
because I think the thing that for me
that I never followed my dreams early on
was the fear of not being able to pay my
bills that's everybody's dream that's
that's everybody's fear which is why a
lot of people are afraid to start their
own Brands and they're afraid to quit
their full-time job the union was paying
me 5 000 every week every other week so
every other week I was I was Hood Rich
at on Thursday on Friday I was Hood Rich
Thursday I was broke right but every
other Friday I was I had money so to
leave that I was forced to leave it but
then hustling to then leave all that to
really focus everything and to put all
my eggs in my basket was scary and so
when I lost the Instagram my whole Focus
was okay [__] that when I come back
we're gonna diversify this brand we're
going to have at least 10 to 15 streams
of Revenue and if 10 to 15 streams of
Revenue are bringing in 5 000 each you
can kind of do the math if we do that on
a monthly basis of course now of course
we're you know making
close to seven figures every month but
so now it's it's a more sustainable
model because now that the brand has
become validated and it's created its
own lane now it's just about how do we
plug and play into other areas yeah yeah
I think like uh the one thing that um
most people you were saying earlier the
fear of paying your bills it's like it
it it kind of like paralyzes people's
progress absolutely like so many people
I know like in my personal life have so
much potential and I always am like like
yo you should do this like I got a homie
who's like in the best shape every works
on every day and I've been trying to
convince him to be like a personal
trainer and start a gym for like it
feels like my entire adulthood and now
he just has a normal job and he's
miserable and I'm like dude you gotta
roll the dice sometimes you have to feel
like your dreams are worth fighting
through the fear you know my whole model
when I wrote my book I must have
forgotten about me I wrote about
um fear over faith a faith over fear you
know when I used to get on a plane early
on I'd be like oh my God this plan is
going to crash this plane is going to
all the turbines going to die but then
on one hand I'm over here listening
gospel music telling people that you
have to have faith in God you have to
have faith in this so I had to really go
back into what I believe what is my
faith what is the foundation of the
Jason Lee person and what is the what is
the foundational belief that the Jason
Lee experience exude Faith over fear so
my faith is I had to find the faith that
I believed in myself enough to get
through the fear and most people when I
talked to him like I was talking about
therapists today I'm in therapy
I was saying to him I'm gonna do I said
I'm gonna do this new show that I'm
selling to this network and I want to
bring you in to do this therapeutic
session but I was telling my creative
idea for I said why don't you do a show
where you sit down and work with people
who've been canceled and work through
why they've been canceled in a way that
makes them you know uncancelable that
sounds like a million dollar idea we're
talking about he was like yeah I would
do that because he rep he works with
other celebrity and public figures I'm
like yo I started telling my ideas and
he was like yo you're you're just you're
able to come up with ideas that is
unlike anybody else I said that's not
true I'm I'm able to focus because that
is something that I believe in and
anybody that believes in something if
they can just push past the fear like I
Feel Like Anything is Possible